Hello, Steve Kaufmann here and today
I'm gonna be talking to Morite2...
Well, I'm gonna be talking to
Tetsuya of Morite2 English channel.
Remember if you enjoy my videos,
please subscribe, click on
the bell for notifications.
And if you follow me on a podcast
service, Please leave a comment.
We appreciate it.
Okay.
So Tetsuya welcome to my channel.
Hello there, thank you for having me.
All right.
So I'll, I'll make a brief
introduction and then maybe you
can provide more information.
Okay.
But I know from personal experience
that a lot of people in Japan are
interested in learning English.
And a big part of that is that there
is an obligation, uh, from employers,
from, uh, educational institutions
in Japan or elsewhere that, that the
Japanese people have to achieve a certain
level in TOEIC or sometimes in TOEFL.
And I think that is part, a big part of
the English learning environment in Japan.
Can you tell us a little about
your channel and the whole English
learning situation in Japan with
specific reference to these tests?
Okay.
Yeah.
So as I told you, uh, my, my channel
is called Morite2 English channel
and then the intended audience,
uh, the people who want to take the
TOEIC test or entrance exams of like
Japanese prestigious universities.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, since...
So these are Students yeah.
Mm-hmm.
So since, you know, English tests are
really important in Japan, so that's
why I teach test taking strategies
or, uh, you know, sometimes I, I
tell them how to study English.
So to do well on TOEIC, I
presume there are two components.
There is actually improving your
level in the language: vocabulary,
your grammar or whatever.
And then the other is understanding,
you know, having a strategy on
how to do well in the exams.
Can you share with us some of
the strategies for improving
English and some of the strategies
for doing well in the exam?
Okay.
So basically, yeah to get a good score...
yeah, of course you have to improve your
English level, right, technique up to
a certain level, but, uh,  even native
speakers cannot get the perfect score
easily because, because they have...
yeah, especially the reading part,
you have to find like several
pieces of information, you know?
So you can't just answer
quickly all the questions.
So that's the yeah one part of the, like
one really difficult part of the test.
And then, so...
Um, yeah, go ahead.
So you gather, uh, several pieces of
information and you have to figure
out the synonyms or yeah, so like the
synonyms are really, really important.
Mm-hmm , uh, in terms of, you know,
finding bits of information in a text,
for example, whether you're reading
or listening but especially if you're
reading, I would imagine the ability
to read fast  is important because
you may have to read more than once
the same text before you find whatever
information they're looking for.
Mm-hmm right.
Actually.
Yeah.
Actually most people cannot finish
this test becasue it's yeah.
You have to read yeah a bunch of  long
texts and then, but, so, so basically
I recommend people, uh, try to find
the necessary information, not try
to read, uh, all of the passages.
So it's a strategy of sort of
skimming the text in order to zoom
in on specific bits of information
so that you can answer the question.
Right?
And so you, what you teach, you
teach a technique for doing that?
Mm-hmm yeah, kind of, and then skimming
and the, uh, scanning are really
important and that's what ETS, uh, the
people who make the test think, but the
problem is we don't learn that in Japan.
We just analyze the sentence structure
and then read, read the sentence.
Uh, and then, then translate
the sentence into Japanese.
So of course it is very time
consuming, so that's why more Japanese
people cannot finish this test.
Okay.
But to be fair, when you are reading in a
foreign language it's a lot more difficult
to skim and, and find, you know, important
bits of information when you're reading.
In your own language it's
like instant meaning, right?
I mean, I can look at the paragraph
of English and I, I see it all.
If I'm learning, if I'm in
another language, I'm kind of
going word for word for word to
try and figure out what it means.
It's not fair to expect the non-native
speaker to have the same ability to
skim or scan as the native speaker,
doesn't matter what the language is.
So...
yeah.
That's yeah, you can say that,
but, but what, what they say
is like, like the test...
so the basically TOEIC tests your ability
to live in the English speaking country.
yeah, basically the United States.
And then, yeah, maybe in other English
speaking countries, such as UK, Australia.
So that's why they ask us to
do just like native speakers.
But of course, of course, that's really,
really difficult for non native speaker.
Right.
It's...
it doesn't matter whether it's a
Japanese person learning English or
an English speaker learning Japanese.
It's the same: reading in another writing
system, reading in another language it,
it's not, it's not that instant meaning
that it is in, in your own language.
Unless you have had so much exposure
to the language and I get back to my
favorite theme of lots of listening and
reading, while the native speaker has
had millions and millions of hours of
listening to the language whether it
be a Japanese or English and reading.
So you, as a learner, you haven't
had that exposure, but the more
exposure you have, the closer you
get to the level of the native.
Right, exactly.
Right.
And the problem is that, you know, the
test is getting harder and harder...
cuz you know, a lot of test takers
learn like useful test taking strategies
and they get, get good scores.
And then the test will become harder.
Right.
One of the things, if you don't mind
me, me saying, so I've always found it
strange that in Japan people take TOEIC
a lot, they take it often, they take it
3, 4, 5.And when I last looked at it, it
seemed like for most universities or for
employment, you need quite a high score.
Which like, over 700 or, or
something like that, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And so if you test and you would get only
350 or 400, that's almost kind of useless.
Right?
So my question has always been
why wouldn't a person wait until
they're confident that they have
a fairly decent level in the
language before taking the test?
Why take the test to confirm
that your level is low.
Uh, you know, if, if I were a Japanese
person, I wouldn't take the test
until I was fairly confident that I
would have at least 750, but a lot
of people in Japan end up with like
300, 400 and they take the test over
and over again, they get 300, 400.
Why not wait until, you know, you're
gonna get 750, or is that not realistic?
I Don't know.
I think the issue is
motivation, motivation.
Like if we don't have
tests, we don't study.
Right.
So  okay.
That's a problem.
So they study for the test.
Yeah, exactly.
So that's kind of sad.
TOEIC could...
TOEIC stands for test of English for
international communication, but...
but yeah, in fact, yeah, we just
study for TOEIC, you know, so, which
has only listening and reading.
So the average person who takes
TOEIC and takes it quite a few times,
like, do most of them eventually
improve up to a level of 750 800?
Or do most of them kind of
stay at that 400, 450 level?
Uh, it depends on the person, but like
if the person likes the test, if, if
the person is into the test, of course
their score usually improves a lot.
But like, if you don't like
English or tests, you know,
of course they just stay...
remain the same.
Right.
So, so it's as much a...
yeah.
Oh, so it's like once they get
the, you know, the, their, uh,
score like satisfactory score.
Yeah.
Most people basically
quit studying English.
So of course their level
will go down again.
So what's that minimum level
that they need in order to not
have to take the test again?
Uh, it depends on the requirements
of the university or, uh, the, the
companies, you know, usually, and in
universities, like many, uh, many of
them ask their students to get over 600.
Mm-hmm  right.
Yeah.
I mean 600 isn't bad.
Uh, but I guess the reality is if they're
not motivated to learn English, then
they're just gonna get a minimum in
the test and then they drop English.
Mm-hmm  yeah.
So that, that is a problem.
So language learning still
comes back to motivation.
If you have a Japanese person who's
really motivated to learn, follows,
you know, American TV programs, reads
books, listens to audio books, is
totally into it, has friends in English
they're gonna do well with no strategy.
They'll still do well.
Maybe they can, they can benefit
with some test taking strategy, but
if they have that kind of a base
in the language they will do well.
Right?
Right.
Yeah.
That's the kind of sad part.
A lot of Japanese people want to
communicate with native speakers, you
know, of English but the, in reality, they
don't have opportunity to use English.
And so like basically English
tests are their only motivation
to keep studying English.
It depends on the person but yeah,
because like, even though we have
like online English conversation,
applications or services, you know,
people just quit studying English.
right.
Yeah.
I can understand that.
So how did you develop
your interest in English?
How did you achieve the level
that you have in English?
Because your English is very good.
Oh, thank you.
Yeah, basically, so I studied English
for the entrance exams of university
and so I got into Keio University.
So one of the best private
universities in Japan.
Prestigious.
Yes.
Yeah.
Prestigious.
And then, so I majored in yeah,
English and American literature.
I wanted to be an English teacher.
So that's what....
And then, but, uh, once I got into the
major, so I realized that there are a lot
of like native speakers of English where
like, uh, at least like native level.
And then I, I was like, oh
my gosh, I learned a lot of
grammar, but I can't speak.
What should I do?
Then I decided to study abroad.
And then, so I studied abroad
in San Diego where I met...
oh, wow.
That's a nice place.
Yeah.
Where I met an American girlfriend.
oh, wow.
That helps.
That's a big advantage.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
That's right.
Yeah.
That helped a lot, I would say so.
So we were together for
like almost five years.
So that's...
My goodness.
Yeah, Lots of opportunity.
Uh, yeah.
So, and, but even to be studying
English or American literature at
university, though, you're doing those
texts in the original, presumably
you're not doing translations.
Right?
Right, right.
Right.
Exactly.
Yeah.
So, I mean, you're, you're
engaged with the culture.
You're engaged with the literature.
You're engaged with the language.
I mean, that's a, a tremendous start
and then to have a, a relationship,
you know, with someone for five years.
I mean, that's a, again, I hope
she wasn't studying Japanese.
Oh man.
She was yeah.
Yeah.
She was studying Japanese so she
complained a lot, like speak Japanese!
I know.
Yeah.
So you have to compromise sometimes.
Yeah, exactly.
So, so then, so while I was in San Diego,
I got interested in cognitive linguistics.
And then, so I finished my thesis and
I moved on to the University of Tokyo.
Yeah.
Then where, where I studied the
linguistics and then after that, so
I went to the states, uh, yeah...
in order to get married to her.
Yeah.
So we started to live in San Francisco,
but, but we broke up eventually.
And then, so then...
this happens
yeah.
And then one person, someone wrote to
me like, oh, so come visit Vancouver.
Yeah.
Canada where you live.
Okay.
Yeah.
Right.
And then, so, so I started to
live in Vancouver after that.
Oh.
Okay.
How
long did you live in Vancouver?
I think nine months or 10 months?
Yeah.
Yeah, almost one year.
And then I met, uh, Korean girl
there so, so I moved to Korea.
my goodness.
okay.
So, so that...
well, your Korean is very good.
We, we spoke for your channel and you
were trying to engage me in Korean, but
I've forgotten so much of my Korean.
I didn't hold up my end
very well, but, okay.
How long did you live in Korea?
Uh, almost one year, but the, the
interesting thing is that's, you
know, I, so first I used English
because my girlfriend spoke English.
But like, after we broke up, so
I had to live alone in Korea.
So I started, yeah, so I had to survive.
Yeah.
Then.
So that's, that's how I, yeah
managed to like master Korean.
Yeah.
I acquired the language.
Your Korean is very good.
And of course, if you're in Korea,
people are gonna speak to you in Korean
and they assume you're you're Korean.
Right?
Right, right.
That mean...
but it's like, you know of it, it's
like, I still have like accents, but, uh
it's I was really surprised, you know,
it's like learning Korean, acquiring
Korean is really, really easy, you know?
Cause the grammar is almost
the same as Japanese.
And then, so I...
and half the vocabulary
is, is recognizable too.
Right.
Exactly.
Yeah.
So I was re...
so like, so I, yeah, that was the
first time I learned that, you
know, it's like, oh, so you...
it's like people in Europe can
speak English really fluently,
fluently because of this.
So...
of course
it's, it's the, of course it's, it's,
uh, similar and, uh, vocabulary....
uh, 50%, like if you're an English
speaker, you wanna learn Spanish half
of vocabulary is familiar to you.
So that's a tremendous advantage.
Right.
So that's...
for sure.
Yeah.
I guess like, you know, when I was in
Canada or  the United States, you know,
sometimes the Europeans said to me,
it's like, oh, you don't know this word?
Oh!
Like, at that time I was like, oh my, man!
But like,  its like when I was in
Korea it's like, oh, makes sense.
Of course, of course.
Well, absolutely it it's the Chinese
vocabulary in, in both cases,
Japanese and, and Korean there's
so much vocabulary from Chinese.
But, and that is like in Europe, in
European languages, there's so much
vocabulary that comes from Latin.
Uh, that, uh, people will
recognize in different languages
and use in different languages.
Exactly.
It's it's like, yeah...
yeah.
Like I had a like huge
advantage, you know, over them.
Absolutely.
When I, when I studied Korean, so...
mm-hmm,  absolutely.
mm-hmm
so it's like I was able to speak...
but you also speak French.
Yeah.
So how did you transition to French?
I was in...
man French.
So when I was in Keio,
so my second year, sec.
Yeah.
We had to study like second foreign
language and I chose French.
So that's why.
And then, so I passed the
entrance I'm of Tokyo university.
And I chose  French.
Yeah.
So that's why it's like, I was able to.
Because the, the question
was just a translation, so
translate  french into Japanese.
So I was able to read, but yes, I
just disregarded the pronunciation.
So that's why, that's why...
To speak well, you have to speak a
lot and you have to be in a situation
where you can speak a lot, which was
my situation when I lived in Japan.
I was speaking Japanese every day, but
if you have that level of comprehension
that you can read well then, uh, you
know, very quickly, if you were to
go to France for a few months, right.
Your level would, uh, your pronunciation
and your ability to produce the
language would improve very quickly.
Okay.
Well, listen.
Very interesting.
So you have, you've been a
bit of a, a language roamer,
an adventurer, uh, picking up
languages here and there naturally.
And at the same time, studying, you
know, cognitive science and linguistics.
And then you're applying all of
that to helping, uh, people in
Japan do better on their tests.
Uh, tests, which are kind of a
necessary evil, uh, in Japan.
And, and also at the same time, uh,
a legitimate reason to learn the
language because you live in Japan, you
don't really need English that much.
But if you have to learn it for
the exam, then you've got a reason.
So it does serve that
purpose of motivating people.
Uh, at some point, ideally, some
people are so motivated by the
language itself that they learn it,
but maybe a majority of people need
that extra nudge from having to
write the test and you help them.
That that's good.
And so, yeah, and the whole issue of, of,
of language learning and cognitive science
is something that I'm very interested in.
Of course, I talk to people
about it, uh, on my channel.
And, and it's interesting to know that,
that there are people in Japan, there
are people, uh, you know, wherever
Korea, France, Russia, who are...
and as I know, because
I've interacted with them.
In fact, there was a polyglot
conference in, in Fukuoka.
We had people from, from Japan, from
Indonesia, from different countries,
uh, Philippines, uh, you know, from
Asia different countries who were
very interested in this subject.
So it's a subject that
has universal appeal.
So it was fun to connect with
a soul brother, uh, in Japan.
Yeah.
Not in Seoul, not in Seoul.
Soul brother.
Yeah.
So, uh, anything, uh, that you
would leave uh, I, we do have, I
do have, uh, Viewers on my channel
who are interested in Japanese.
I have viewers on my channel
who are Japanese people who
wanna improve their English.
Any final thoughts you
wanna leave them with?
Yeah, right.
So it's like, yeah, for the
Japanese people who studied English
so please try to speak English.
Like don't be afraid of making mistakes.
So I was like...
yeah.
In Japan.
Yeah.
It's like even, probably
this video will be like that.
So a lot of people, you know, write bad
comments if somebody speaks English.
So that's like...
terrible.
Terrible.
I agree with you and the same, same
with, and just to continue on that
thought, you are never going to be
as comfortable in a foreign language
as you are in your own, right?
So you pronounce your own language better.
You use the words better, uh, but the
fact that you are able to communicate
in another language, that's good.
And to criticize people who don't
hit the a hundred percent perfect
to me is, is, is extremely bad.
Don't criticize people.
Don't correct them.
Just, you know, congratulate them
on what they've been able to do.
And people should congratulate
themselves when they're able to
communicate in another language.
Similarly, when we learn Japanese, if
we don't have all the niceties of the
politeness, uh, in Japanese, keigo
or whatever, don't worry about it.
I, I correct me if I'm wrong, but you
know, no Japanese person is offended
uh, if you don't hit the perfect level
of politeness, it doesn't matter.
Uh, you have to be respectful of people.
Uh, and common sense dictates how, you
know, how one behaves respectfully.
But you don't have to have the total
a hundred percent keigo nailed down.
You're not gonna offend anyone.
Exactly.
Yeah.
And I think sometimes people get so
wrapped up in this politeness and oh geez,
if I say this I'll be offending someone.
You won't.
I lived there for nine years.
I never saw anyone get offended because
someone had clumsy usage of Japanese.
Would you agree with that?
Yeah.
Sure.
No problem.
Yeah.
It's like, it's extremely
difficult for foreigners to learn
honorific expressions in Japanese.
Of course, of course it
takes a lot of exposure.
It takes living in there living
with people, experiencing it.
You can't read it up in a
book and then get it right.
Okay.
Tetsuya, thank you very much for
visiting with me on my channel.
Okay.
Right, please subscribe to my channel too.
Yeah, no, I'll put a link to
your channel, the whole thing
will go in the description.
Okay.
Yeah.
Thank you.
And come and subscribe to Tetsuya's
channel, especially if you're a
Japanese person working on your
English and you're gonna learn
a lot of things that are useful.
Okay.
Thank you.
Bye-bye.